(Audience clapping)
- I love, like you're
welcome to my show any time.
Because you brought cake and wine,
- [Martha] I did.
- which are two beautiful pairings.
- A Bundt cake, isn't
it something special?
- A Bundt cake, yes.
You tell us about your cake,
and I'm gonna tell you
how good this wine is.
(audience laughing)
- Do you like cake, Kobe?
- I do.
- Do you eat cake?
- I do now, yes, yes.
(audience laughing)
- I do now too.
- I will go to town on
cake and wine all day.
- Well that's a Bundt cake,
and I always hated Bundt cakes,
'cause they were that
ordinary Bundt shape,
you know the ones that just,
they don't look like this,
and then we came up with
some new Bundt cake pans.
- Okay, fancy.
- [Martha] And yeah, see how deep
the beautiful design is on that.
- You can ice in between those--
- [Kelly] It does look like architecture.
- Yeah it does, it's just so beautiful,
and they're all different
kinds of sizes and shapes
of the Bundt cakes.
So this is our newest one, we made a--
- This is really good too.
- [Martha] Oh, isn't that good?
- Is this yours?
- That's our Aligote.
- [Kelly] It's really good!
It's smooth!
- That's a white burgundy.
A lesser burgundy, I call it,
but it's from the
Burgundy region of France.
I curate wine.
- I love French wine.
- I like to curate.
- God bless you for curating
this wine right here.
- I choose wines from all over.
- I like the French 'cause
they don't do the additives.
I love French wine.
- Oh, well, there's so many
good wines in the world,
but I find that most people don't know
how to choose a good wine.
So I do all the choosing.
I have all the fun.
I taste so many wines.
We taste hundreds of wines a month,
to choose just a few very good ones--
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- That you can sell at a good price.
- If you ever need someone
to help you with that,
I'll drink with you.
- When you're in New York,
when you're in New York--
- I'm with you, too.
Dynamic duo.
- We got you!
Dynamic duo!
We're the wine dynamic duo!
(audience cheering)
- And, let's see how this cuts.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, look how fluffy.
- [Martha] Really nice.
- [Kelly] I mean who doesn't like cake?
- That's a whipped cream pound cake.
- A whipped cream pound cake.
- Yes, you mind if I serve--
- Yes, serve guests first.
- Your guest first? (chuckles)
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I'm getting Bundt cake
from Martha Stewart, boy.
(audience laughing)
- I just love
that we're getting served
cake by Martha Stewart.
- Bundt cake.
- My life has exponentially gotten cooler.
- I hope it's not too dry.
Is it too dry?
- Mm-mm, aw, that's the best.
- I have to ask, did you like--
- I think we need a cappuccino or--
- I love a cappuccino,
but why ruin this moment?
- Oh yeah, you can have wine.
- Yeah, wait, I was like--
- Let me taste a little piece,
just to make sure it's delicious.
- This is ridiculous.
- Okay, mm.
- Get it.
- [Martha] It is good.
- Yeah it is.
- I don't mean to like,
eat front of all y'all,
but this is, this is insane.
- It is so good.
- We can cut it up and give to everybody.
- Oh my God, there's not enough!
They'll be like (roars)
(audience laughing)
Later though, you're doing
a Thanksgiving dinner demo,
so how do you celebrate Thanksgiving?
- Oh, well, we usually
have a big Thanksgiving,
maybe for 40 people or so.
Everybody wants to come to my house,
'cause I raise my own turkeys.
- Sure.
- So we have heritage breeds.
You know what heritage breed turkeys are?
- No, but I'm sure they taste great.
(audience laughing)
- Oh, they do, really good.
And, so I do turkey three
different ways, and uh--
- You do three different turkeys?
- Oh yeah, three different ways.
- I love that you said, "oh
yeah," like that's normal.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, 30 people you need three turkeys.
- Okay, I got you, okay.
- They're like 25 pounds each,
so, we're doing a turkey in parchment,
wrapped in parchment,
so you start off baking it
just at a low temperature,
and then you raise the temperature,
and you take the paper off.
- Mouth is watering.
- [Martha] And it gets all
nice and glossy brown skin,
- I'll bet your turkey is the jam.
And then we get spatchcock,
spatchcock turkey.
You ever do a spatchcock turkey?
- I'm just realizing
that there are three
different ways to do turkey.
(audience laughing)
- I'm still stuck on three right now.
- What did you say? A Spatch--
- Well there are many
more than three ways.
Spatchcock.
You um--
It's nothing dirty, it's nothing dirty.
- It doesn't sound good.
- It means you split the cock.
The hocklets of a rooster.
(audience laughing)
- It really, it used to
be, it used to be about--
- Somebody's gotta do it.
- Chicken.
- Somebody's got to do it, Martha.
- What it means is that
you take out the backbone
with a pair of scissors,
and you spread it flat,
and it cooks in a third of the time.
- Oh!
- So for those of you who are oven-poor,
if you only have one oven,
you have to bake the pies,
you have to do all the sides,
you have to do the turkey.
- I love that you said oven-poor,
most houses have one oven.
(all laughing)
I love it, it's amazing!
I want your life!
So you have a show with Snoop Dog.
- [Martha] One sip of wine,
and I'm already giddy.
- Oh, me too, I'm a lightweight.
(laughing)
So you do have a show with Snoop Dog,
which I love, I've seen it,
and I think it's hilarious.
But I also heard you might
be launching a CBD line?
- Oh, I am working with Canopy,
the big company up in Canada.
They actually hybridize and grow cannabis,
and they're also doing
now hemp in a big way.
So I'm working only in CBD,
I do not touch cannabis.
- You don't touch THC?
- No, not like Snoop, not like Snoop.
(audience laughing)
Snoop, Snoop--
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding!
- [Martha] Snoop lives it!
(audience cheering)
- No, it is very healing,
like, CBD is very healing as well.
- [Martha] CBD is different.
- Some great properties.
- So many, and I'm working
on not only food products,
but also skin care as
well as pet products.
- [Kelly] That's great!
- Oh my dog gonna be chilling!
(audience laughing)
- We got a black lab, he's already chill.
He's gonna be like,
- Lying there with his four legs up.
- [Kelly] Living his best life.
- Chilling man!